what was it like linking with uh with uh
gerald oh man cool i mean so basically
we uh
i did the la leakers freestyle like my
first future like trip to la or
something like that and he he was like
the first like
artist like besides like maybe like the
one like macklemore or something that
had ever like reached out to me you know
what i'm saying like but the leaker's
freestyle comes out and that same day he
hits me up he's like yo you [ __ ] snap
this shit's hard
keep going you're going crazy and uh
and then like two years passed but i i
didn't press the issue because i'm just
like i don't know i'm not the guy who's
i don't know i don't i don't ever want
to like be a weirdo and try to finesse a
friendship or nothing before me but like
my management and [ __ ] goes back with
him so eventually like we had a record
that made sense and we send it and he
was on and it was love bro like he was
on something like oh yeah let's make it
go up
and it was hella easy bro so really it
just came about on some like he hit me
up in the dm being like you snapped on
that freestyle i just
didn't ask for nothing just waited for a
couple years and then finally he's the
best and he's a good dude bro we shot
the video and he was on set all day
turned up when we were hitting the
costume egos together it was lit that's
my guy yeah she's like uh for being like
a
superstar that he is is like the coolest
[ __ ] man bro the cool rant and
randomly too like he'll like he just
like he'll favor the tweet on some like
stupid [ __ ] on some random just like
he's just a genuinely good guy you know
but he's turnt up